Being on a hormone blockers, is there any blood work or other tests I should ask my
ecology for to keep an eye on?
No, not really.
If you want to know your hormone level, the best test to do is the Dutch test, D-U-T-C-H,
and you can order that through loop of labs, but you really don't need to run it because
you're if you're on hormone blockers, you're bad estrogen, all your estrogen is going to
be in the cellar.
So there's no need to spend the money on that test.
Who would run that test?
Somebody who just followed out they have cancer or, and their doctor wants to put them
on hormone blockers, and they don't want to go on it, they want to look at their hormone
levels.
I just ran a test for somebody and just went over with them two days ago and her bad estrogen,
her 400-oxy esterone, was elevated, not good, even though her E1, E2, E3, those are your
standard estergins, were actually the low normal for some reason, most likely a cytokrome
P450 pathway was pushing it to be converted to the bad estrogen, which can drive cancers
hormone-related cancers.